voilà un jeu vidéo classique c'est un
jeu de football je le mets en route moi
je suis le joueur ici et avec ce petit
manche à balai je vais me promener voyez
vers l'avant vers l'arrière maintenant
clairement Ferrand vous pouvez en faire
autant regarder bien ce joueur ici ce
n'est pas moi qui l'actionne c'est un
jeune je crois que c'est Philippe ou
Rémi à Clermont-Ferrand qui le bouge et
nous pouvons ainsi jouer l'un contre
l'autre alors je prends le ballon
j'attaque je passe au dessus de lui
j'essaye de marquer un but toute façon
je vais pas y arriver je tire à côté et
voilà j'ai raté ça fait rien c'est pas
grave que je gagne que je perde ce qui
compte c'est que par les lignes
téléphoniques qui sont ici vous les
voyez là nous avons pu
faire en sorte que ce jeu vidéo à Cannes
puis cette manipulé a clairement Ferrand
et aussi à Thiers une autre ville qui a
pu donc jouer toute l'après-midi avec
nous c'est cela l'interactivité